[Music]
all right let's go down the street to my
hometown Nashville and talk to Lexi
what's up
Lexi hi how's it going rocking and
rolling what are you up to good nothing
much just trying to Cal my nerves about
this call but oh you're all good you're
all good what's up um okay so I have a
kind of description that I'm just going
to read because this topic is even hard
for me to kind of explain
um so I hope that's okay but I am a very
anxious and I guess you could say
paranoid person I was diagnosed with
postpartum depression around four months
ago but my doctor felt like the main
cause of that was my sleeping habits as
long as I can remember I've been scared
of very irrational things um it's pretty
embarrassing to admit honestly since um
I'm an adult now but I remember feeling
this way as a child um and I feel like
it got a lot worse in high school but as
an adult I still struggle with this it
affects my everyday life um I can
pinpoint certain characters that I've
seen in TV shows or on the news that
trigger me more than others but um
mostly when I'm alone or when it's dark
my mind is pretty much convinced that
the same episodes I've seen on these TV
shows are going to happen to me even
though I know it's not real so I don't
sleep well because I'm super anxious I
have one eye open and I just last night
was up for hours with just super I and
paranoid
thoughts yeah I know that's a lot well I
was going to say welcome to my club I'm
happy to have you as another Charter
Member you just described me about 12
years ago so well that makes me feel
good it is awesome to have you so good
thank you I really hope you can help
because I've seen um three or four
therapists over the years and nobody's
ever been able to help me or even give
me like Sound Advice that helps me get
to the next step so
I'm like I feel like if anybody could
help it would be you so well I
appreciate that um what what are some
things that they have told you to what
are some attempts they have made in the
past um so I did the first therapist I
saw I was in high school um my mom had
just seen multiple episodes of me having
pretty much panic attacks because I
would get so scared of things that were
clearly not real um so I went to a
therapist and his ideas were to at the
time I was like scared of taking a
shower when I was alone because I had
seen a show where a serial killer killed
girls in the shower so I would not
shower if nobody was home um so he just
encouraged me to do that when no one was
there and proved to myself that nothing
was going to happen um and that didn't
really help at all um and then as an
adult I've seen therapist and they
pretty much just tell me to change my
thoughts or to pray and as much as like
I want that to help it just hasn't done
anything for me oh man hey if you were
here I would ask is it okay if I just
hook you for a minute I'm
sorry yeah it's pretty hard I'm really
over it yeah I can see so you're um the
guy you actually saw in high school was
was closer to the truth okay okay um now
had I been working with a teenager I
would not have done it that way because
it's pretty abrupt what he was doing was
the the the nerd word is exposure
therapy MH and so let's take a Snak
let's you have a phobia of a snake and
like you can't breathe you don't sleep
like snakes snakes Snak Snak snakes
snakes right yeah what they'll do in
especially with youngsters but even with
adults is they will start with you just
sitting in the room and I want you to
imagine a
snake and we'll do that for like and
then we'll play a we'll play a game like
just to cleanse your your mental pallet
and then all right you're going to for
five for five seconds for 15 seconds
you're going to picture a
snake and then it moves gradually
towards you're going to color a coloring
book that I have here which is like like
clearly children's cartoons of snakes
you're going to color it we're going to
do it together and as an adult you feel
like this is the most ridiculous thing
I've ever done it's
embarrassing but you color it and what
you're slowly doing over time and you
end up with the last session is he
brings in a giant snake or you'll go to
the zoo and you hold a snake
together cuz what you've done is you've
gently over time taught your body tiny
step by tiny step that that's going to
we're going to be
okay now I want to suggest to you
something totally different that's what
he was trying to do and I actually think
there would have been some help there
back when you were a kid but just going
basically what he did was all right just
go to the zoo and hold a snake you'll be
fine and your body was like pretty much
like now so yeah he skipped a bunch of
steps but I want to ask you a different
kind of question okay okay what
if what if your body's
right
um that's a good question let me ask you
this I guess I'm gonna I'm gonna say
this um and it's gonna sound crazy I
don't think there's something wrong with
Lexi okay
okay I don't think something's wrong
with
you I want to at least sit for a minute
with the idea that Lexi's body is
working
perfectly so if that was the case
and we backed out 30,000 feet and I was
sitting right next to you so we're all
good
yeah what is Lexi scared
of that's a good question I've tried to
think about this um a few times and it's
let me say it differently I asked it
wrong yeah what is Lexi's body trying to
protect her
from um I I really don't like the
feeling of being scared I think that's
like above a layer above where I guess
you're probably trying to go but I don't
like the feeling of being scared is
something I think I'm scared of okay
absolutely and so like for example last
night I heard a it was storming in
Nashville I'm sure you heard it was it
was mad house my daughter ended up in
our bed yeah was a whole thing yeah oh
gosh yeah it was loud and I heard
something it ended up being our shutter
fell off our house but in the middle of
the night I heard the bang and in my
head I was like okay someone just came
in our backyard they're going to come
kill us like they my kids are going to
have to watch I had these crazy thoughts
spiring throughout my head and I like
fully believed that that was about to
happen Okay and the feeling of like the
anxiety and just like the waiting I
guess is really what triggers me the
most was like I couldn't relax because I
just was like so sure something was
coming and I don't know I want to
suggest something else yeah that's
that's a drug for
Lexi okay you get
high off the flood of adrenaline and
cortisol and here it comes it's showtime
it's game time
now and when you don't have that in your
real life and maybe you grew up you and
I could sit down for an hour and by the
way you're Nashville come down and visit
me in the studio that'd be fun we can
hang out but like like for you're like
yeah for sure never gonna happen ever so
um
if you grew up in a wild situation in an
unsafe home your body put a GPS pin in
in these moments of I'm Free
Falling okay and maybe you didn't maybe
you grew up in a perfectly safe home and
cool but if no I did okay so if yeah you
grew up in chaos or not yeah in chaos
okay so think of it this way your body
put a GPS pin in at any moment this
thing comes
down and it is simply
all the time 247 365 your body is trying
to take care of
Lexi yeah it's just trying to take care
of you and so it has put a bunch of GPS
pins in darkness and in noise and in
hovering scary pictures do you have an
do you have abuse in your
background um kind not um physically but
mental yeah
okay yeah from I had a pretty rough
relationship with my dad and there were
quite a few episodes um that happened as
a child my mom is convinced that that's
what this is all rooted in but um but
but when when somebody says like oh it's
all rooted in this what they're going to
tell you is so now that's not there just
get over it yeah and what I want to tell
you is it's baked into your nervous
system it's part of you so your body is
is working
great the one freaking guy that was
supposed to take care of be the safe
warm place for his daughter went to war
with
her right
yeah and so you pull that image away and
your brain goes searching for the next
image to plop in there and you just
happen to sit down in front of a TV show
where someone's getting hacked up in a
shower yeah and you're like oh that's
how it will happen yeah and then
eventually you have to take a shower you
have to and you figure it out and figure
it out and figure it out and your body
goes all right we're that's not it it's
GNA be this and it just keeps moving and
moving and moving and moving M I would
be stunned and I never ever ever ever
ever do this on this show
okay I in fact I'm not going to do it on
this show I want you to go talk to a
counselor and I want you to ask if they
will give you an OCD diagnostic or an
OCD um analysis okay okay I would be
surprised if there's not some sort of
the trend line between OCD and anxiety
is very thin but when I sat down with
the doctor and walked through and he was
like oh dude clearly right here it it
gave me so much peace
okay okay yeah that's interest because I
almost included in my question I don't
have I'm not diagnosed with OCD but I'm
pretty sure that I I want you to go
don't don't do a Google diagnostic
because that is but I do want you to go
talk to somebody and say hey would you
give me an inventory and see if this is
what this
is because it just moves because my my
get my your doctor's right nothing in
your body works if you're not sleeping
yeah how old's your baby
um I have a one-year-old she just turned
one and then a six-year-old and an
eight-year-old stepson so how um we have
a busy house how how dark can we get
real
quick quick whatever whatever you you
think did you have some looping pretty
awful
thoughts yeah I did um and we also had
my daughter had really serious health
issues um last May and um she she pretty
much did die um at the hospital and they
were able to save her but that
definitely spiraled me as well um but
hold on you had some thoughts that you
were concerned if somebody knew it was
in your mind they're going to take your
kids didn't you oh yeah yeah for sure
okay
yeah and then you take those thoughts
and you bury them in the deepest
recesses of your soul and you can't
sleep you can't breathe and then your
machine Loops up again and it goes in
again and it goes in again and then is
your husband a pretty good guy
he is yeah he actually is the one that
told me about your show I'm so thankful
well he's he's grasping at a ghost
because he loves you so much he doesn't
know how to reach you because you're so
far inside of
yourself yeah but I need you to hear me
say you're not
broken thank you do you trust
me yes I trust you I know it's weird to
think that your body's working just as
it should here's what we have to do it's
um there's like a you ever been in the
shower and it's facing in the door and
so you open the the shower door and you
turn on the shower and it shoots you
right in the face and you're in your
full clothes and you're like what
because it's just all we need to do here
is turn the nozzle the other
way your body's working great it has
just identified Darkness as the end of
time it is identified loud noises or
scary thoughts as it's all over now and
it is not something that you can think
or just quote unquote pray your way up
it is a biochemical response your body
dumps cortisol and adrenaline into your
body that's why you can't sleep has
nothing to do with you being crazy it
has to do with your body is filled with
fight ORF flight
chemicals yeah I always say I'm like if
I could run a marathon it would be in
the middle of the night exactly and you
just lay in bed and you're like all
right well I'm just going to lay here
I'm gonna lay here right yeah yeah and
then no matter how much you're just
laying there at 6:14 can I have a snack
can I have a snack right just starts up
again yeah yep okay pretty much that's
how it goes you're not
crazy that feels good to hear okay
you're not crazy yeah so I want to give
you you got a lot of work ahead of you
I'm not gonna lie to you okay I do think
there's
um I'm going to send you both of my
books cuz I wrote them for
you okay a lot of people get a lot of
benefit from them but I wrote them for
you because you and I have very similar
situations okay that's helpful yeah
thank you I want you to know this though
you're going to have to be willing to
let this go as an
identity okay not the you're gonna have
to just force yourself into a scary
moment you are going to have to do that
but that's down the road what I'm saying
is right now you have identified
yourself as I'm an anxious parent an
anxious person and I'm scared of being
scared
yeah the problem is you wear that as a
as a
badge as a label that you've put on your
lapel yeah that's true and I want that
crap
gone you're a awesome badass mom and
wife who grew up in hell and has done a
pretty amazing job with three little
ones of her own that's who you
are you're not a scaredy whatever your
body yeah your body overreacts for sure
and you hear here how I here's what I'm
I want you to do stop being afraid of
your own body because what you're going
to end up doing is you're going to start
asking yourself what are you trying to
protect me from that sentence changed my
life because I'd put my hand on my chest
and I'd say what are you trying to
protect me
from my things was the economy every
time I looked at a I saw a red Ticker on
the ticker tape a little red arrow
pointing down my body B dropped into my
my stomach dropped it was game time it
was fight ORF flight every time I got a
a bill in the mail woo I it was it would
never stop you can't live like that
right but I started asking myself what
are you trying to protect me from oh
from the stock market of course it's
going to crash the people are
crazy and of course it's going to just
keep coming back until it
doesn't yeah and it was this gentle dude
my body's working awesome it's just
identified the wrong
villain but you have to decide to give
up the identity that I'm crazy cuz
you're
not yeah that's I guess I never really
thought about it that way but I I
definitely do when I think about who I
am that is at the top of the list is I'm
I'm a scaredy cat I'm afraid of
everything you're not you're not you're
a little girl wondering what what you
did so badly what was so bad about you
that your dad treated you like
that yeah that that makes sense tonight
I want you to write that eight-year-old
girl a
letter and say dear 8-year-old Lexi I
freaking love you and I'm holding you as
tight as I can because that should not
have happened happen to
you and if I'd been your mom that
wouldn't have
happened I can do that okay you got to
let that little girl go and you might be
a 10-year-old and there might be a
15-year-old and as you write these
letters more crap's probably going to
come
up but I want you to slowly sit with
them and I want you to make that a
practice I've got several letters
written to myself over the years here's
another I want to give you this this
glimmer of hope Before I Let You Go Okay
because you and I could talk for hours
just kind of piecing this thing together
yeah but it I think more than a bunch of
tasks that you could Google at the end
of the day I think I need you to hear me
say you're not crazy I need you to hear
me last
night what
happened okay I've been sick and so I
was sleeping
upstairs in our guest room
okay it's right up it's it's a converted
Attic So it's right up against the
ceiling and last night the storms were
nuts yeah they were and I woke up
my heart was racing the wind was just
whipping the rain was so hard bam bam I
heard the trash cans flying around
outside because I live out in the
country and I started
laughing I started
laughing and I thought man they are
getting it out there and then I said
thank God we needed this rain
bad and I rolled over and I got an 87 on
my sleep score last night which is
pretty high for me wow okay okay here's
why I tell you that I need you to
believe me that healing is possible if
you put this work
in okay you're GNA have to have some
time in the darkness right they're and
they're probably GNA have you draw a
picture of what of dark of a dark room
with a little kid in
it and if you want to do that with your
husband you all do it together because
don't do this by yourself but y'all two
draw a picture of just for a week at
nighttime just going to draw a picture
of a little kid in a room that's dark
and when your body starts going I want
you to feel it put your hand on your
chest and go man my body feels like
there's somebody coming in this door
right
now but I'm safe
now and then I want you to draw that
picture on a nightly basis or an
afternoon basis with your husband until
you don't uh until your body doesn't
take off on you
anymore okay and then right it's just
going to keep ramping up and ramping up
until you can't freaking wait for the
darkness and by the way every once in a
while I go into the house and I'm like
something doesn't feel right in here I
don't it's just trying to take care of
me again it's fine see I'm not I'm not
I'm not going to war with my body
anymore yeah that would be a great
feeling would that be awesome okay can
you undec war against Lexi starting
today that doesn't mean anything's going
to be better tomorrow you're still gonna
have trouble sleeping tonight all that
let's undec war from Lexi tonight and I
want you to put a journal by your bed
someone's probably told you this every
irrational wild thought I want you to
write it
down okay okay oh I heard the shutter
blow off someone's in the backyard we're
all going to die write that down get out
of your body and onto a piece of
paper okay
okay will you do that yes I can do that
that seems like a tangible step will you
and your husband come over and get some
free coffee and hang out yes he would
love that we actually saw you one night
at Five Guys um and my husband was like
that's joh I had no clue who you were at
the time and I'm like who is who the
heck is John deloney he was like
fangirling um and then we he ended up
showing the your show and I've listened
ever since but he would yeahall come up
here tell them tell them you on the show
and that uh we're gonna hang out and
then we'll be it'll be awesome okay okay
and um if you come visit me in person
I'll give you a couple of names of some
local people that I trust that I think
would be worth seeing that would be
amazing I was going to ask if you could
do that thank you yes all right hang on
the line I'm going to hook you up with
those free books and um we'll get them
shipped out to you um and I hope to see
you guys in the studio
soon